allez on va l'accueillir il vous a
entendu arthur est avec nous ce soir ça
te va bien et je suis très content et la
même aussi le premier en bas aura le
droit de prendre la carte qui est ici et
de la mettre dans la lah la balle dans
le visage syrie les équipes gentiment eu
l'élégance de ne changer tee shirt
wen ont mis un t-shirt pour sa berge
peut pas même pas bougé débat ça te va
très bien bien ça veut bâtir bien savoir
où dit mais non ça te bout d'une part
bien avec moi aux motos cinquième set
très serré et on était alors à faire le
chip ou me pour savoir qui prend
l'ascenseur et qui prend les escaliers
d'accord attention hein syrie oui
chiffonniers j'ai pas joué depuis 30 ans
alors pierre feuille ciseaux pas
d'accord attention le puits est
éliminatoire qu d'accord si tu fais le
puits on appellera tf1 tu seras même
viré le tfc quoi le puits le puits c'est
ça d'accord ok attention chez fo mais je
casse les ciseaux donc il ya là il y
avait dix pays qui sont là on va se
rappeler dans une minute d'accord moi je
vais prendre l'ascenseur c'est partir au
débat c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
il est mort cyril soit trouvée
seiko pied
[Applaudissements]
à la santé de tpm p
tout va bien
côté vendeurs je vais vous raconter
tian a tenté ce qui s'est passé despatie
vi bat cac est à fait incroyable abordée
alors que tu vaux d'ascenseur j'ai
appuyé sur des étages avant il a des
mecs bien démarqué au 2e ont fait
arrêter plus je crois que jamais de leur
vie se sont fait insulter comme ça la
mode lors d'une scène des mois alors
quand ça s'est produit pour être appelée
boko
mais des français le 2 mai prochain